all right so welcome back to 8701 we'll
continue our discussion on
feminine calculus and here we dive into
a toy theory so this theory is a toy um
and it's just an example to illustrate
finance rules
um what we do the simplification we
employ here is leaving out the spin of
the particle involved
if we consider the spin um we add
another algebraic complication which is
right now
confusing so we leave this out for now
we come back later to this
so we're supposed to have three kinds of
particles involved here particle a b
and c and so we can have a primary
vertex where this all three
particles are interacting like shown
here
so particle a
might decay into particle b and c
um you can assume that particle a is
heavier than the sum of b
and c so this is kinematically allowed
um we might also have corrections
involved here as shown here
and what we'll be interested in is now
for example calculating the lifetime of
this particle a um
we might do this just for this primitive
vertex or we might do this for this
complicated set of corrections
we might also be interested in
calculating
scattering processes where particle a's
get us with particle a and produces
particle b and particle b
or we scatter particle a with particle b
and so on
so in this theory at the end of the
lecture we have all tools in hand to
calculate this
no worries i will not leave you alone
with this in this lecture we go through
the
recipe and then later on we'll see how
we actually apply this
so let's look at this recipe so the
recipe has a number of steps
and the key is to just follow those
steps
um in order to get to the desired result
the first step
is to label incoming and outgoing
formamenta of particles
so we label them with p1 p2 and 2pn
and we also want to label all internal
momenta so if we have an
internal line then we want to label this
internal momentum with q1 q2 and so on
we want to add errors to each line to
keep track of
what is the positive direction as we
discussed before particles might travel
backwards time
you know typically anti-particles and
for those we have to make sure that we
correctly account for the momento
for each vertex
we have a factor we write down this
vector minus ig
where g is the coupling constant so this
is a measure of the strength of the
interaction involved
then we have a propagator so for each
internal line the internal lines are
also called propagator
we write down a factor i over
qj squared minus mj squared c squared
note that
q j squared doesn't have to be m j
squared c square
meaning that the particle can be off of
shell of mass shell
you also see that there is a
complication in the integral when you
actually have those vectors being the
same
you want to make sure that energy and
momentum is conserved so for each vertex
you write down a delta function
um with those um
with the conditions this is for this
three vertex where
momentum of the first one pluses second
plus a third is equal to
zero only then the value of the velter
function is 1.
remember there's a minus sign somewhere
most likely here for this
k1 value then you want to integrate over
all
internal momenta so for each internal
line
you write a factor one over two pi
to the fourth power um d4s on your
momentum and then
this all will result in a delta function
which you just eliminate and you do that
by
um by multiplying it you erase this
delta function
and you replace it by a factor i
so this seems like very confusing why do
you at delta functions first and then
you erase them later
notes in
in in
the fermis golden rule we use the
squared of the amplitude
and you also saw that the phase base
factors already have this kind of phase
of this um delta functions included
so we get out of the complication that
we don't really know what the square of
the delta function is
by erasing it by adding the i
and then keeping track of the momentum
conservation
this conservation here when we
apply the facebook factor and then voila
you just calculated a matrix element all
right
so those are the rules now the key is
to practice how to apply them so what
we'll do next
is to practice using this toy experiment
and how to calculate
the matrix element the phase space and
the set decay rates and cross sections
and then the following step we will see
how this all
unfolds when we have a real theory like
qed
like the weak interaction the strong
interaction
you